for those who join just joined i'll just
reintroduce myself i'm de lara de ken
and
i just recently graduated from bachelor
university
and i did my internship at uh
pine biotech in the omixlogic research
fellowship program and
my project was on the radio the threat
that radiation poses to humans in space
and i will be i analyze the adverse
effect of specifically high
led radiation on the mouseket microbiome
and how this affects the nervous system
and causes psychological disorders
so i'll give a short introduction of how
bioinformatics is involved
and then i'll give an introduction to um
my
project specifically how i analyze my
data
and then i'll be sharing my results and
how i concluded this
and um i think that bioinformatics is
really
important because um during my time at
the wet lab i
realized that we're producing such great
amounts of data
that we need to process but
the speed of processing that data is not
fast enough and
by informatics and the machine learning
and other new technologies that are
involved
are a great way to speed this process up
and another thing that i'm fascinated by
and by informatics is that
the same raw data that is collected for
one project can
also be used for other researches as
well
and um so i i want to
shortly talk about my experience at pine
biotech
and uh why i joined it and it was
because
they have courses for everyone from
beginner
and then they bring them up to a
more professional level and that's why i
had an
amazing experience especially joined by
my wet life experience
earlier so it was like seeing the bigger
picture
and um to start with my project
basically it was uh on the prospects of
space travel
and how the advancement of space travel
affects
uh the astro scientists in space
and as subrajeet it was talking about in
his uh
presentation a lot of different fields
uh are involved in astrobiology and
they don't necessarily have to uh be
simply about
looking for life in space or you know
they don't have to be focused on one
thing or the other
and that's why i decided to focus my
project specifically on the health of
astro
uh astronauts and astro scientists
and um as you can see here on the
chart on the graph on the right the iss
which involves different countries and
different agencies
has started doing their projects in
numerous different fields including
biology and physical science
and um i decided to choose this
the health of astro scientists
specifically
because to be able to continue this
research out in space
we have to have healthy um scientists
out there
and um i also think that
the landing of perseverance and the
speed up of
our space travel goals as humanity
especially um by with starting colonies
out in space
it's really important to focus on
research that affects the human health
so there are different types of
radiation out in space
um including ionizing and non-ionizing
radiation
and my focus was specifically on
ionizing radiation because it has
high energy and this can cause chemical
reactions
and i will frequently be talking about
something uh
known as high led radiation and this
stands for
linear energy transfer which is the
dosimetry it's a measure of the effect
radiation has on materials
and this is a very curious type of
radiation because
high led radiation can easily be
shielded for
larger structures but it can pass
through
microscopic structures such as cells
and uh as we know radiation can have
various effects from you know major
effects like cancer to minor effects
like
attention loss and as you can see here
this is
this was taken from a report from nasa
and they were
analyzing how these
listed issues will
be controlled or uncontrolled in the
next 10 years this is a 10-year plan for
the planetary mission
and as you can see at the bottom
radiation exposure to human health is
greatly uncontrolled
whereas above you can see other
things like bone fracture or reduced
aerobic capacity
and host microbio microorganism
interactions
and these are uh partially controlled or
um we're hoping to control them by 2028
but what we need to understand is that
the
radiation exposure affects all of the
above
disorders so another reason why it's
extremely important is because as you
can see on the right
the six months on iss
on average the radiation exposure is 10
times as much as the
abdominal ct scan so it is extremely
important to consider radiation in our
studies
so uh for my methodology i separated it
into
three different steps major steps and
this was data exploration statistical
analysis
and my conclusions so for the data
exploration first i found
a data set from ncbi which contained
80 samples from the mouseket microbiome
and these
these atvc samples were separated into
uh two categories and basically this was
based on radiation and days so there was
0.1 and one gy radiation
and the samples were collected 10 and 30
days post radiation
and then using the um the
t bioinfo platform i use the data 2
pipeline and the phyllo seek pipeline
to find the abundances and also produce
graphs include including the pca nmds
and shannon index which i will be
talking about
in detail and uh to ensure
that my observations from these outcomes
were correct i
conducted some statistical analysis
including anova and t-tests
and as for the drawing conclusions part
i was
particularly focusing on lower doses
since they penetrate cells
more easily and i wanted to see if the
days also play a role because it's
important in the acclimatization of
bacteria
and also because these bacteria can be
targeted for therapy for different
diseases
here we can see an nmds graph which is
stands for a non-metric
multi-dimensional scaling graph and
here as you can see my focus was on days
because i saw a better separation
between 10 and 30 days post radiation
and as you can see for yourself as well
the 10 is circles and 30 is triangles
and the 30 days post radiation was more
spread out throughout the graph
here we see a shannon index graph
and this involves the biodiversity
of the samples and it measures the
richness and evenness of the species in
the sample which is equivalent to the
effective number of species
so here as you can see when the
comparison
is made between all four doses of
radiation
lower doses which is 0.1 and 0.25 gui
radiation
the biodiversity decreases in the
samples
um and then i
this was another uh graph output from
the phyllo c
pipeline and for here we can see several
different things at once
including how the doses and days affect
the abundance
and these otus which are operational
taxonomic units
which will be equivalent to the species
as you will see later on
and how these are related to each other
and one thing that we can see is that
otu four and five are related
and we can also see that for
compared to zero gy radiation 0.1 and
0.25
at 10 days shows lower
uh the lower abundances of bacteria
so i decided to focus on these and i did
a statistical analysis
first i started out with anova which
uh i used three doses zero gy for my
control
and point one and point two five gui
because um from the previous
uh file seek out pipelines as you
i told you the lower doses were more
significant
so i decided to focus on those and then
my outcome was that
the days did not have as much of a
significant effect
but the dosages did and between these
two variables there was no interactions
so i conducted a t test keeping the days
constant
and just analyzing uh the doses of
radiation
compared to my control group and i
found that these four otus otu three and
four which
which are related and five and eight
which are related as you can see
and and the heat map as well these
were the significant otus and these
were um significantly lower at 0.1 gui
radiation
when compared to 2.25 and
this was according to my threshold that
i set at 0.25
0.05 p value and i wanted to also
check the abundances because
it is important to see which families
and genus of species
increase and decrease and if these
correlate to my statistical analysis
here you can see that i compared those 0
and 0.1 gy
and the lactobacillus bifido
aircipelotrikasi
families decreased whereas the vehicle
microbia increased
and when i conducted uh profiling and
aligned
these results with my t-test results
i found that um otu 3
4 5 and 8 as i mentioned previously
were in the lactobacillus and by for the
bacterium family
and as you can see uh the four species
like the vessels cause erie and john
sonny and
by for the victim longam and castorius
respectively were the results of my
profiling
so why did i specifically focus on these
well that's because these four species
of bacteria have metabolized that
affect the nervous system through the
gut brain axis
and they do this through the
enterodendritic and vagus nerves
which play which play an important role
in
transferring the stimulus from our gut
to our brains
and these four species were associated
with
associated with the production of gaba
which stands for gamma aminobutyric acid
which is the chief
inhibitory neurotransmitter in the
central nervous system and
uh gaba is extremely important because
when
it produced in low levels it causes
depression and anxiety
because of the lack of um because of
lack of inhibition
of the stimulus so there's constant
stimulus and
these bacteria have protein coding genes
called glutamines and glutamine
synthesis as you can see in this
gabaergic synapse
they are gs and gls
and uh they these are the same genes
that are in the gaba pathway of
humans so we can assume that as the
abundance of
bacteria that have these protein coding
genes decrease
the amount of gaba in our nervous system
will also decrease
so we have two pathways that we can take
uh
from here and that is we can either
produ uh we can either supply the body
with exogenous kava
or we can produce uh we can give the
patients probiotics
but exogenous gaba in previous research
did not give the desired effect so
probiotics is a more
reasonable solution a more effective
solution in this case
so i can conclude this and gather up
the findings of my research by saying
that
according to my initial hypothesis lower
doses of high let radiation has a
greater impact on the gut by
phytobacterium and
lactobacillus abundances especially
at 0.1 gy and the acclimatization period
can be deduced as 10 days that's because
at
30 days post radiation this uh when we
analyze the samples we did not see
a significant difference on the contrary
the abundance levels were slightly
increasing
and this could be a result
of the length of exposure because we did
not expose
these mice to radiation uh
for very long and i think that
um this can be further research
we are using uh combined effects of
radiation and microgravity
and also increasing the length of
exposure to see how it affects
um the nervous system and
the abundance of bacteria so we can
easily say that this was a precursor
study on how probiotics can be used as a
treatment in psychological diseases and
how
radiation affects the nervous system
and um
[Music]
yes as for my limitations
um one of my limitations was on
taxonomic profiling because
as you know in bacteria um
there are sequences that are very
similar especially because for
profiling we use 16s regions of bacteria
and for the same genus they are very
similar
so it's difficult to pinpoint which
species of bacteria you're dealing with
uh and another one was that the
optimizing the parameters of the
pipeline but this
helped me improve my approach to
technical problems
uh encoding and and dealing with
um machine learning and its parameters
also another limitation um that was
caused due to the collection of samples
in the wet lab with the
sample size and doses there were 10
samples
per category and if this sample size
increased we could have more accurate
results
and we should also have in between doses
in in between our four categories of
doses
and we also look forward to
research conducted on humans and
astronauts directly
and that's because that's because as
much as we can
analyze samples from mice we do not know
how the mechanism truly works in humans
so um there are some researches that
collect
samples from astronauts but since the
durations
of that astronauts are out in space is
much longer
that uh that is another limitation for
those researches and
here is my references
and i'd like to thank everyone for
attending and listening and i would like
to thank everyone at pine biotech for
their help
and especially harpreet kohr and
ilya brotzky because they were my
mentors
and they helped me a lot during this
research and thank you to rutwi for
uh initiating the cyomics
seminars because i think they're quite
helpful